- It's not my butt, it's my lower back,
and it's really classy.
(upbeat music)
- Every holiday and
birthday, I tell my husband
that I'm going to get his
name tattooed on my butt.
I think that when I
reveal the tattoo to him,
he's totally going to believe me.
- He never takes me seriously,
and this is probably why.
- She told me two weeks ago,
that if I ever got a tattoo
of her name, she would
probably break up with me
because she thinks it's the
stupidest thing on earth.
- [Voiceover] He could be either
really excited or he could
be horrified and relieved
that it's a joke.
- I think he's going to be
like, "Oh, that's so sweet.
"Thank you."
- But like, secretly hate it, you think?
- Oh, yeah. Inside be like, crying.
- I can't feel how big it is. Oh, my god.
- It's everything I hoped it could be.
- I'm going to get her.
(upbeat music)
- So, I know I told you that
we're here to talk about our
first Christmas together, that's a lie.
- You are kidding, what is this?
- I got something today, for you.
- I told you that I had a secret
present that I was putting
together.
- Mmhmm.
- Earlier today, we had
a tattoo artist come in,
and I got something.
- Can I show him?
- [Voiceover] Mmhmm.
(laughter)
- Why are you getting naked?
(upbeat music)
(laughter)
- I'm glad it's spelled correctly.
- Oh, my God.
No, you didn't.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- No you didn't.
You did not do this.
- Yes I did, it's right here.
- It's winter so you'll be
able to cover it up with --
- Did you get a tramp stamp?
- Yeah.
- With my name on it?
- Yes!
- I can't believe it, no.
- You don't believe?
- No, I don't believe you.
- Are you embarrassed?
- It's just a lot to process.
- Do you like it?
- I love it. (laughs)
- It's not real.
- This is real! And it
hurts, so stop touching.
- Do you not like it?
- I, it's just a lot.
- What do you mean it's a lot?
- It's just a surprise.
- You're crazy! (laughs)
- Oh God, you hate it.
- (laughs) No, I mean, I love you.
- Alright, fine, it's not a real tattoo.
I was trying to prank you.
- It was absolutely not going to work.
- It's not fair, you prank everybody.
- Do you know what else?
Can I tell him?
- Do I want to know?
- It's fake.
(laughter)
- (laughs) We're kidding.
- What if this was real?
- It would be awful. I
mean, I can't break up
with you over that.
- I would've like, let
it ride for a while,
but then maybe we would
hit up the removal shop.
- What?
- You were already going there.
- You would get it removed?
- It's just so not you.
- That was a perfect set-up.
- You believed me.
- I totally did.
- You know what though?
In the end though ,the jokes on me
because this is on for two weeks.
- Oh!
- So, that's fun.
- Well now I love it.
(laughs)
- And then I'm thinking,
your mom is going to kill me
for inspiring you to get this.